este vídeo le ayudará a comprender la
neumonía y la manera de manejar su
recuperación
mire el vídeo completo para obtener más
información sobre cómo manejar la
neumonía
si usted ha estado recientemente en el
hospital con neumonía es importante
entender cómo recuperarse correctamente
cuando vuelva a su casa la neumonía es
una infección que se puede dar en uno o
en ambos pulmones
y los alvéolos pulmonares en el extremo
de las vías respiratorias se inflaman e
irritan
y se llenan de líquido
lo que hace que tenga dificultad para
respirar
otros síntomas de neumonía incluyen tos
que puede producir una mucosidad espesa
dificultad para respirar
y dolor en el pecho cuando respira
profundamente o tose fiebre sudoración o
escalofríos
a baja temperatura corporal en adultos
mayores
y dolores musculares y sensación de
cansancio general náuseas vómitos o
diarrea
y dolor de cabeza
es importante que comprenda que seguirá
teniendo los síntomas durante la
recuperación en su casa
y la tos debería mejorar paulatinamente
en una o dos semanas es probable que
necesite varias semanas para que el
apetito los hábitos de sueño y los
niveles de energía vuelvan a la
normalidad para poder recuperarse
adecuadamente deberá tomarse un tiempo
sin ir a trabajar y sin seguir su
programa de actividades normales
afortunadamente puede manejar mejor la
neumonía si sigue las siguientes
instrucciones del equipo de atención
médica tomar los medicamentos según lo
indicado
y realizar los procedimientos de cuidado
personal
y realizar algunos cambios en su estilo
de vida
y proteger los pulmones de otras
infecciones y sustancias irritantes
y cuidarse significa tomar los
medicamentos exactamente como lo indicó
su médico
no omita ninguna dosis
no deje de tomar los medicamentos aunque
se sienta mejor
tomé nota de cualquier efecto secundario
e infórmese lo a su médico no tome
ningún medicamento o suplemento de venta
libre sin antes consultar con su médico
y cumpla con todas las citas de
seguimiento acordadas con los miembros
de su equipo de atención médica
usted puede contribuir a su recuperación
si realiza algunos procedimientos
simples en su hogar tales como ejercitar
los pulmones durante el día realiza un
par de respiraciones profundas dos o
tres veces por hora las respiraciones
profundas ayudan a desbloquear los
pulmones si desea obtener más
información sobre los ejercicios de
respiración consulte a su médico
tener todos como pues normal y ayuda a
eliminar líquidos de las vías
respiratorias
de modo que tome medicamentos para la
tos sólo si su médico le dice que puede
hacerlo proteja a las personas que los
rodean teniendo a mano un pañuelo de
papel para cubrirse la boca cuando tosa
y si tose con mucosidad no se la trague
escupa la en un pañuelo de papel y
deseche lo de forma adecuada es posible
que su equipo de atención médica les
recomiende un drenaje postural para
realizar esto debe recostarse con la
cabeza en una posición más baja que su
pecho
esta posición ayuda a drenar el líquido
de los pulmones también puede indicarle
que se dé pequeños golpes en el pecho
para ayudar a eliminar la mucosidad a
través de la tos para esto
recuéstese con la cabeza en una posición
más baja que el pecho y desde golpes
firmes en el pecho con la mano ahuecada
el equipo de atención médica puede
proporcionarle las instrucciones
específicas un humidificador o
vaporizador puede ayudarle a respirar
más fácilmente la humedad de un baño
caliente también puede ayudar
recuerde que estos dispositivos deben
limpiarse diariamente no limpiarlo
adecuadamente puede dar lugar a otra
infección similar a la neumonía los
cambios en la alimentación pueden ayudar
en su recuperación una buena
alimentación ayuda a que el cuerpo
combata infecciones y se recupere más
rápidamente una dieta equilibrada
incluye frutas verduras carbohidratos y
proteínas todos los días tome de 6 a 8
vasos de agua jugo
usted diluido al día a menos que su
médico le haya indicado otra cosa no
beba alcohol mientras está en
recuperación dormir lo suficiente
también hace que el cuerpo se recupere
más rápidamente si la tos interrumpe su
descanso por la noche duerma siestas
durante el día
proteja los pulmones de los irritantes
no fumen y permita que otros fumen a su
alrededor no salga de su casa si la
contaminación del aire es elevada
evite el humo de la chimenea
proteja los pulmones de cualquier otra
infección lavándose frecuentemente las
manos con agua caliente y jabón
evite la exposición a multitudes y a
personas con resfriados o gripes
pregúntele a su médico si debe vacunarse
contra la gripe o la neumonía
llame a su médico si tiene más
dificultad para respirar
no puede tomar una inhalación profunda
y le duele el pecho al respirar
la fiebre regresa
todas con cosida de amarilla verde con
sangre o maloliente
experimenta vómitos
se siente excesivamente somnoliento o
confuso
tiene dificultades para pensar
o tiene los labios o las puntas de los
dedos azules hable con su médico si
tiene alguna pregunta sobre su plan de
tratamiento medicamentos o cambios de
estilo de vida que lo ayuden a manejar
la neumonía